Salut à toi jeune entrepreneur !
Si aujourd'hui je me permets
de te contacter
c'est pour une raison très simple.
Je vais te parler de Charles Ponzi
qui a escroqué 30 000 personnes,
à hauteur de 10 millions
de dollars, quand même.
A Boston dans les années 20.
De Bernard Madoff
qui pendant 48 ans
a mis en place une arnaque
qui a pris une ampleur hallucinante.
A hauteur de 50 milliards d'euros.
Ou encore d'Herbalife
qui a quasiment aucun employé,
mais qui a réussit quand même
à vendre ses produits.
Qu'ont en commun
toutes ces organisations ?
Le système pyramidal.
L'idée est très simple, je vais prendre
tous tes sous pour te rembourser
et gagner toi aussi des sous,
tu vas prendre les sous des autres gens.
Qui devront aussi
trouver d'autres gens
pour prendre leur sous
qu'ils me donneront,
et je t'en redonnerai une partie.
C'est simple.
Alors est-ce que tu veux faire partie
des 5 % du sommet de ma pyramide,
qui arnaque 95% des autres ?
Moi je crois que
la question est vite répondue.
Loïc, générique !
- Fanny, générique !
- Quoi ?
- Système Pyramidal...
[Musique]
D'abord, qu'est-ce qui définit
un système pyramidal ?
En fait, il s'agit
d'une escroquerie,
comme ça c'est clair
pour tout le monde.
Escroquerie, dans laquelle
l'initiateur de la pyramide
invite des investisseurs à effectuer
une dépense plus ou moins importante.
Il invite ensuite ces investisseurs
à recruter à leur tour,
des nouveaux entrants,
qui vont eux-mêmes
effectuer la même dépense.
Et les versements
des nouveaux entrants,
vont servir à rémunérer en priorité
les intérêts des premiers
investisseurs de la pyramide.
Et après, on redescend
un petit peu et ainsi de suite.
Donc les étages supérieurs
de la pyramide
recevront des montants
de plus en plus importants.
Tandis que la pyramide elle,
elle continue à recruter.
Mais cette progression
ne peut pas être infinie.
Ne serait-ce parce qu'il y a un nombre
limité d'êtres humains sur terre.
Il n'empêche que ça ferait déjà
une sacrée pyramide,
si tout le monde y participait.
C'est le principe de l'exponentiel.
On a déjà vu ça
dans des vidéos ensemble.
Si on considère qu'à
chaque étage de la pyramide,
il faut recruter deux fois plus
de personnes qu'à l'étage précédent.
Alors ça devient
l'échiquier de Sissa.
J'avais fait une vidéo
là dessus en 2016,
je vous la mets dans la description.
Au cinquième rang de la pyramide,
il y a déjà 31 personnes
dans la pyramide, dans le système.
Et au 64e rang de la pyramide,
il y a ce chiffre-là,
clairement imprononçable.
En fait, c'est deux milliards de fois
le nombre d'habitants qu'il y a sur terre.
En seulement 64 étages
de la pyramide.
Lorsque la pyramide ne peut plus
s'étendre, qu'elle peut plus recruter.
Alors les étages inférieurs ne peuvent
plus recruter de nouveaux membres.
Et l'étage qui est juste au-dessus,
perd toutes leurs mises.
Mais c'est pas très grave,
parce qu'il reste encore
peut-être d'autres personnes.
Et en fait, le bas de la pyramide lui,
se met dans une galère.
Tandis que le haut
de la pyramide, eux ça va.
ça va, genre bien.
Eux, ils sont pas impactés
par l'écroulement du système,
ils se sont déjà
enrichi dès le début,
sur le dos des premiers
membres des étages inférieurs.
Autrement dit, ils s'en sont mis
plein les poches, tout va bien.
En général, les ventes pyramidales
un peu déguisées
proposent une gamme
de produits assez simple.
Généralement, sans marque
ou assez méconnu du grand public,
ou très inhabituel.
Ce qui rend leur valeur marchande
difficile à évaluer pour l'investisseur.
Moins le nouvel entrant s'y connait
dans le domaine du produit,
plus il va être facile
de lui retourner un peu le cerveau.
Mais il existe même des systèmes
pyramidaux sans aucun produit.
Alors ça c'est fabuleux,
ils appellent ça
les cercles d'abondance
ou des cercles de richesse.
En gros, ça se joue à la confiance.
Le but, c'est d'arriver
au centre du cercle,
qui regroupe
une quinzaine de personnes
pour récupérer
environ 80 000 euros.
Pour commencer,
on doit verser 10 000 euros.
Et en général, c'est une valise
de cash de 10 000 euros,
il n'y a pas de compte bancaire.
Et on doit trouver en même temps,
deux nouveaux entrants
qui rentrent avec nous.
Donc comme ça,
tu embarques bien deux copains
ou deux personnes de ta famille,
à galérer, à larguer
comme ça 10 000 euros,
peut-être les économies d'une vie.
Et ensuite, le but du jeu
c'est de trouver une personne
qui va elle aussi
rentrer dans le cercle.
Donc à l'étage inférieur à toi.
Et qui va aussi emmener
deux personnes avec elle.
Et c'est là, où toi
tu vas changer le cercle
et te rapprocher
un petit peu du centre.
Les structures pyramidales
sont illégales, pour deux raisons.
La première, c'est que
les systèmes pyramidaux
ne créent aucune richesse,
aucune valeur.
L'argent passe simplement
des rangs les plus bas,
aux rang supérieurs jusqu'au
sommet de la pyramide,
qui elle se fait abondamment
servir à chaque fois.
La seconde raison, c'est que
les systèmes pyramidaux sont,
comme vous avez compris,
précaires et donc voués
mathématiquement à l'échec,
soyons clairs.
ça peut paraître sexy,
ça peut paraître
faisable intellectuellement.
Mais c'est impossible
mathématiquement
que ça fonctionne dans le temps.
Pour trouver des nouvelles recrues,
les membres
des systèmes pyramidaux
ont tendance à chercher
autour d'eux,
des gens qui acceptent
de leur faire confiance.
Et donc qui acceptent d'investir
une certaine somme en échange
de promesse de fortune future,
ou de revenus réguliers.
Pour y parvenir, ces membres
font appel au marketing de réseau.
Donc bien souvent, c'est réduit
à la famille et aux amis proches.
Donc ça crée des tensions
dans la vie en plus.
La vente pyramidal,
c'est donc immoral.
Elle se contente pas
de vous arnaquer,
elle encourage ses membres
à profiter de son entourage.
De tata Jojo, de tonton Loïc,
ça va tonton ?
- ça va et toi ?
- Tonton
- Ah ouais !
- Petite voix aiguë en ce moment
- C'est moi hein !
- Jeff Panacloc ?
- Je sais pas ce qui m'a pris.
Pour résumer, une organisation
fait de la vente pyramidale
si les participants font leur moula
grâce au recrutement,
avec un investissement
de départ évidemment.
Et non pas avec la vente réelle,
des biens et des services
aux consommateurs.
[Musique]
En 1919, Charles Ponzi, 37 ans, Italien,
domicilié à Boston aux États-Unis.
Il cherche des fonds
pour lancer un magazine
qui serait consacré à l'export.
Alors, qu'il correspond
avec l'étranger.
Il découvre à l'intérieur
d'une lettre venue d'Espagne,
un coupon réponse
international, un CR.
Il remarque que ce coupon
a été payé en pesetas.
Donc l'équivalent
de un cent Américain.
Or à l'époque, ce coupon peut être
échangé dans une poste de Boston,
contre un timbre de six cents.
Soit six fois la valeur
du CRI de départ.
Et c'est sur ces écarts de change,
que Ponzi décide de faire de l'argent.
Le 26 décembre 1919,
Charles créé une société qui s'appelle
"The Securities Exchange compagny".
L'idée annoncé à ses clients,
c'est d'investir de l'argent de départ
qui est rémunérée à hauteur
de 50% au bout de trois mois,
grâce au change de CRI.
ça fonctionne sur le principe.
Par exemple, Nicolas investit
100 dollars en janvier,
Ponzi fait son bail avec les CRI.
Et en mars,
Nicolas récupère 150 dollars.
ça se tient.
ça se tient tellement que
dans la vraie vie ça fonctionne,
Au bout de trois mois,
les premiers clients reçoivent
l'argent de leurs intérêts.
Ils se disent alors que le système
de Ponzi fonctionne bien.
Et depuis juillet 1920,
c'est 30 000 clients
qui ont déjà déposé
plus de 10 millions de dollars
au bureau de la compagnie.
Ponzi empoche à cette période,
jusqu'à un million
de dollars par semaine,
dans les poches de sa société.
C'est une somme absolument
faramineuse pour l'époque.
Parce que c'est pas
les mêmes valeurs,
vous savez, en fonction
des époques, tout ça.
Mais en juillet 1920, le Boston Post,
fait un article qui va semer la panique
chez tous les investisseurs
de chez Ponzi.
Clarence Barron,
analyste financier écrit,
que seuls 27 000 coupons postaux CRI
sont en circulation aux États-Unis.
Soit 133 millions de moins,
que ce qu'il aurait fallu à Ponzi
pour investir tout l'argent,
que les investisseurs
avaient mis chez lui.
Donc il y a une grosse panique.
Il y a de nombreux investisseurs
qui commencent à comprendre
qu'il y a quelque chose
qui cloche.
Et ils retirent tout leur argent.
Ponzi rembourse 2 millions
de dollars en deux jours.
Et le 26 juillet 1920,
il encaisse encore jusqu'à
200 000 dollars par semaine.
Quand enfin,
le procureur Joseph Pelletier
demande à ce que Ponzi arrête
le recrutement de nouveaux clients.
Donc il a plus de nouveaux clients
qui rentrent chez lui.
Et là c'est un souci, parce que
s'il n'y a plus d'argent entrant,
il peut plus en sortir.
Le Boston Post
enfonce le clou en août,
en écrivant que Ponzi
a déjà fait de la prison.
C'est le retour de la panique
et des demandes
de remboursement
de tout l'argent, toute la moula
qui était chez lui.
Ponzi commence alors
à remplir des chèques
à l'ordre des clients mécontents.
Mais là où ça devient ouf,
c'est que la commission bancaire
voit une catastrophe arriver.
Et commence même à craindre
pour le système bancaire de l’état !
C'est hallucinant,
qui pourrait s'écrouler
si Ponzi se mettait à rembourser
tous ces épargnants d'un seul coup.
Donc les chèques
émis par Ponzi
sont volontairement
refusés par les banques.
Et c'est à la mi-août,
que l'escroquerie
éclate officiellement au grand jour,
sous toutes ses coutures.
En gros, Ponzi payait bien
les intérêts de tout le monde.
Simplement les intérêts,
pas la mise de départ.
Avec une partie de l'argent
des nouveaux épargnants.
Donc on avait l'impression
que le système était opérationnel,
mais à partir du moment où
il y a plus de nouveaux épargnants.
Ou que tout le monde voulait
se retirer en même temps,
la pyramide s'est effondrée.
Charles a été emprisonné
et condamné à cinq ans de prison.
Il en fera au final que trois.
La nationalité américaine
lui a été refusée,
mais il restera tout de même
aux États-Unis.
Il est mort ruiné en Amérique latine
en 1949, à l'âge de 66 ans.
[Musique]
L'affaire Madoff,
c'est un autre exemple qui illustre
la taille gigantesque que peut
avoir un système pyramidal.
Bernard Madoff,
c'est la légende de wall street.
Il a réussi à créer et administrer
une chaîne de Ponzi, de 1960 à 2008.
C'est il n'y a pas si longtemps.
Pendant 48 ans, il a réussi
à faire fonctionner un réseau,
en promettant un retour sur
investissement de 12 % à ses clients,
ce qui est énorme
dans le milieu bancaire.
Parce que c'était
un taux fixe et sûr.
Enfin soit disant sûr,
selon Bernard.
En 1960, Madoff a 22 ans,
il a 5000 dollars dans ses poches.
Et créer un fond d'investissement.
Alors au départ, tout est légal,
Madoff reçoit les capitaux
de ses clients.
Il émet dans des fonds
d'investissement à risque,
dont la performance est réputée
comme étant supérieure à la moyenne.
Mais c'est là où ça commence
déjà à déconner.
Quand les gains obtenus étaient
en dessous de la rentabilité
qu'il avait un peu
promis à ses clients,
au lieu de réduire le montant
distribué aux investisseurs,
c'est un truc à risque.
Madoff, prenait l'argent des nouveaux
entrants pour les rémunérer.
Et ça c'était le début
de sa pyramide.
Mais vous allez voir
l'histoire est folle.
Puisque Madoff tenait
en apparence ses promesses,
sa réputation grossissait.
Et les nouveaux entrants arrivaient
avec une forte somme en plus,
pour entrer dans le système.
Pour entrer dans le système,
il fallait au mieux être parrainé
et quoi qu'il arrive,
mettre beaucoup
de pognon d'un coup.
ça roule pendant 48 ans
et c'est la crise financière de 2008
qui a vraiment raison
du système Madoff.
Alors que les bourses,
les différentes bourses
qu'il y a dans le monde s'effondrent.
Il y a de nombreux investisseurs,
qui demandent à l'homme d'affaires
de récupérer leur argent.
Parce qu'ils se disent,
ça va partir en fumée avec la crise.
Et c'est peine perdue, puisque
cet argent n'existe déjà pas.
Il a servi chaque année,
à payer les intérêts de
ces mêmes investisseurs en fait.
Madoff prévient alors son fils,
qui prévient lui-même les autorités.
Et le FBI embarque Madoff.
Je raccourcis l'histoire,
il y a plein de documentaires
que je vous invite à regarder
sur l'histoire de
Bernard Madoff.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que Madoff aurait fraudé
l'ensemble de ses victimes
pour un montant de plus
de 65 milliards de dollars.
Et que parmi elles,
on pouvait compter des fondations
comme celle de Steven Spielberg.
En France, il y a des sociétés
comme BNP Paribas, AXA,
le Crédit Agricole, Groupama,
La Société Générale,
qui en ont fait les frais.
Qui avaient investi dessus.
Les petits épargnants français eux,
auraient été touchés à hauteur
du coût de 40 millions d'euros.
Puisque les banques comme ça,
avaient l'argent des petits
épargnants de France.
Et allaient investir ensuite
directement chez Madoff.
Mais du coup,
ceux qui se sont fait vraiment avoir,
c'est ceux qui avaient mis
leur argent au départ.
Madoff a été condamné à 150 ans,
c'est beaucoup, de prison.
Et aujourd'hui,
il est bien sûr ruiné.
Pour l'anecdote,
Madoff s'est recyclé en prison,
comme étant parrain
du marché du chocolat chaud
auprès des autres détenus.
Il est incarcéré en Caroline du Nord,
il a mis en place un système,
où il achète tous les produits
de la marque Swiss Miss.
Et il le fait en direct,
directement auprès de l'intendant
de l'établissement pénitentiaire.
Et ensuite, il les revend
plus cher, dans la cour.
Voilà, on se refait pas quoi.
On pourrait penser aujourd'hui,
que ce système illégal est connu
de tout le monde et n'existe plus.
Mais c'est complètement faux.
Ces dernières années,
il y a plusieurs entreprises
qui ont été pointées du doigt
parce qu'elle étaient soupçonnées
d'utiliser ce même système.
Et parmi elles, il y en a peut-être
qui vont vous parler.
Il y a It Works, Herbalife,
Geteasy, OneCoin, etc.
Leurs réseaux se développent
de plus en plus vite, pourquoi ?
Parce que maintenant,
il y a des réseaux sociaux.
Donc c'est hyper actif,
hyper rapide.
Il y a la création de faux comptes,
des publicités mensongères.
Ou simplement des personnes
que vous connaissez
dans votre entourage,
ou dans vos amis,
qui du jour au lendemain
vous propose du maquillage.
Et des produits pour la santé.
Je suis sûr vous avez
déjà vu passer ça.
Les premières victimes,
ce sont les nouveaux entrants
et c'est principalement des gens,
qui sont à la recherche
d'un revenu complémentaire.
Et la plupart du temps aussi,
qui sont un petit peu précaires.
C'est limite du mentalisme.
On leur propose
de rentrer dans un réseau,
pour avoir des réductions sur un pack
de produits introuvables ailleurs.
Mais un petit peu coûteux.
Et après, une fois
qu'ils ont acheté le pack.
On leur explique
que le simple fait,
de recruter des nouvelles personnes
dans ce même réseau,
leur permet de gagner de l'argent,
et de toucher un pourcentage
pour chaque parrainage.
Et qu'au final, c'est quand même
bien plus rentable
que de vendre des produits
qu'ils avaient acheté si cher.
C'est vraiment un droit d'entrée
déguisé sous des produits.
Pour la société
It works par exemple,
qui vend principalement
des produits beauté et minceur.
Il est demandé aux nouveaux entrants
d'acheter un pack de présentation,
et ensuite de recruter
de nouveaux collaborateurs.
Qui eux aussi,
vont acheter leur pack
de présentation et ainsi de suite.
On retrouve donc bel et bien
le système pyramidal de départ,
caché derrière des produits,
qui au final ne se vendent que très peu.
Ils sont juste une parade
un peu légale,
qui marche sur le fil de la loi.
[Musique]
Prenons le cas d'Herbalife.
C'est hallucinant.
En 1981, Mark Hughes
créé aux États-Unis,
une marque de produits
de nutrition amaigrissants
et des soins personnels
cosmétiques, etc.
Herbalife.
Deux ans plus tard, la société
ne tourne pas trop mal.
Puisque son chiffre d'affaires
est de 2 millions de dollars.
24 ans plus tard, 1885 milliards.
C'est une société active dans
le monde entier, ils sont partout.
Le système
de distribution d'Herbalife,
a été au centre
de toutes les polémiques,
parce que la vente des produits,
est effectuée par
les consommateurs eux-mêmes.
Ils sont obligatoirement
adhérents de la société.
Contre une petite marge
sur le prix des produits.
Ils ont pour mission évidemment,
de recruter de nouveaux adhérents.
Pendant les réunions d'information,
il y a des responsables d'Herbalife
qui font miroiter
des salaires mirobolants.
Mais c'est toujours à l'oral,
il n'y a pas de trace écrite.
Ils incitent les adhérents
à ratisser de plus en plus de monde,
même auprès de leurs proches.
Ce qui permet à la société
via le système pyramidal,
d'élargir son réseau de vendeurs
et de consommateurs
sans avoir à payer de personnel.
Donc il y a, et le pyramidal
et un côté un peu Uberisation.
Il faut payer
un pack pour entrer,
mais la société génère ici réellement
de l'argent grâce à ses produits.
La première personne
a tout intérêt à faire venir
d'autres personnes
à rejoindre le concept,
parce qu'elle va
recevoir une commission
sur chaque inscription directement.
Cette commission
devient en réalité
le moyen de payer la personne
qui est au dessus, évidemment.
Et qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
la personne qui en dessous ?
Elle va chercher d'autres membres.
Et elle et son parrain toucheront
encore un peu plus et ainsi de suite.
Vous avez compris le principe.
Donc le système pyramidal,
draine non-stop des gens
et leur entourage qui cherchent
eux aussi à gagner de l'argent
par cette même méthode.
Et quand arrive le moment où
plus personne ne peut être recruté.
Eh bien ce sont
comme d'habitude,
ceux qui sont en haut de la pyramide
qui raflent le marché.
D'ailleurs, le turn over se fait
que à la base de la pyramide.
Jamais au dessus.
ça, ça change pas.
Et plus on se situe
à un niveau élevé de la hiérarchie,
plus les commissions et les bonus
chez Herbalife, sont élevés.
Et plus le prix d'achat
des produits est réduit.
Il arrive donc régulièrement
que des consommateurs,
qui avaient été approchés
dans un premier temps
pour acheter des produits,
soient amenés à devenir
eux-mêmes distributeurs.
Ne serait-ce que pour obtenir
les réductions sur l'achat des produits
que eux-mêmes consomment,
pour leur consommation personnelle.
Cette affaire a été
rendue publique
par l'investisseur
et activiste Bill Ackman.
Ackman, c'est un investisseur
américain qui créé en 2004,
le fond d'investissement
Pershing Square Capital.
En 2012, il a alors 46 ans.
Il investit depuis son fond à lui,
1 milliard de dollars
pour parier sur le fait qu'Herbalife
va tout simplement s'écrouler.
La raison selon lui,
la société ne vaut rien puisqu'elle
est fondée sur un système pyramidal.
Et dans les dix jours
qui suivent cette annonce,
la valeur boursière d'Herbalife
chute de moitié.
C'est énorme.
La société se défend.
Et Michael Johnson, qui est
le directeur général à ce moment là.
Va même jusqu'aux menaces,
en disant que l’Amérique
ne se portera que mieux
quand elle sera
débarrassée de Bill Ackman.
Donc c'est une vraie
guerre dans les médias.
Qui poussera d'ailleurs Ackman,
à s'offrir les services
d'une protection rapprochée,
parce qu'il y a beaucoup trop de gens
qui sont dans la société Herbalife.
C'est une guerre de ouf qui a lieu.
Je vous invite à regarder sur internet
des coupures de presse de l'époque,
entre Herbalife
et l'activiste Ackman.
Mais en 2016,  la commission
du commerce américaine, la FTC,
qui était alors chargée
depuis deux ans de déterminer
si Herbalife reposait
sur une pyramide de Ponzi ou pas.
Ne suit pas Ackman.
Elle considère pas qu'Herbalife
suive un système pyramidal.
Il y a un accord qui prévoit
quand même par contre,
que la société Herbalife
verse 200 millions de dollars.
Et qu'elle restructure
en profondeur ses activités,
pour que les membres
soient récompensés en priorité,
pour ce qu'ils vendent et non pas
pour le nombre de personnes
qu'ils recrutent autour d'eux.
Mais il y a quand même,
juste un espèce d'arrangement
avec la présidente de la FTC.
Qui a tout de même
rappelé que la société
n'a pas hésité à faire
miroiter à ses distributeurs,
la possibilité de gagner
des milliers de dollars par mois
et même de devenir riche.
C'est une publicité mensongère,
parce que dans les faits,
la plupart d'entre eux
ne gagnent pas, peu.
Mais souvent pas d'argent du tout.
Les pyramides de Ponzi ont
encore de beaux jours devant elles.
60 pyramides de Ponzi ont été
découvertes aux États-Unis, en 2019.
C'est comme ça tous les ans,
donc il y a à peu près une
qui est démantelée par semaine.
ça représente
3,24 milliards de dollars,
d'argent escroqué tous les ans
selon les estimations.
Et encore, je dois être
en dessous de la vérité,
parce que le montant collecté
auprès des investisseurs
un peu naïfs ou qui se font avoir,
a doublé par rapport à 2018.
Et ça, ça s'explique encore
une fois avec les réseaux sociaux.
Les arnaques
se portent sur l'immobilier,
sur des panneaux solaires,
sur des diamants,
sur des crypto monnaies,
sur des produits de beauté.
Et comme je vous l'ai déjà dit,
plus les placements sont atypiques,
moins les investisseurs
s'y connaissent.
Et moins ils se méfient du coup.
Et tant qu'il y aura des
nouveaux marchés à conquérir,
les pyramides de Ponzi
continueront de fleurir.
Sauf si le monde entier est informé
du fonctionnement de ces pyramides.
Auquel cas plus personne
ne se ferait avoir.
Est-ce que vous voyez
où je veux en venir ?
Donc n'hésitez pas à partager
cette vidéo à une personne,
qui elle-même devra
recruter deux personnes
qui partageront cette vidéo.
Et encore deux personnes,
deux personnes, et toi plus moi...
En vrai, plus elle sera vue,
moins il y aura
potentiellement de victimes.
Et si vous voyez un jour,
quelqu'un de votre entourage
qui se lance dedans,
sur facebook ou ailleurs.
La question elle est vite répondue.
Vous lui faites voir cette vidéo,
ça va être dur à accepter.
Surtout si il ou elle
a acheté un pack au départ.
Mais en vrai,
vous allez lui rendre service.
N'oubliez pas de laisser
un like à cette vidéo,
je m'appelle toujours...
Toujours Fabien Olicard,
toujours ou pas ?
- Ouais, ouais.
- Oui, okay.
Okay cool, Fabien Olicard.
Donc abonnez vous à cette vidéo...
- Ah ouais.
- Donc abonnez-vous
à cette chaîne YouTube, c'est gratuit.
Pensez à activer la cloche,
sinon vous ratez les vidéos quand
elles sortent et c'est dommage.
C'est juste à côté
du bouton abonnement.
Vous pouvez me rejoindre
sur les autres réseaux,
c'est complémentaire.
Il y a TikTok et Instagram,
il y a plein de choses,
il y a Twitch et tout.
Ici, je vous mets
deux autres vidéos.
Là c'est celle sur l'échiquier de Sissa
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure.
C'est pas si simple à dire,
un échiquier de Sissa.
Et là c'est sur une arnaque,
qui a été faite
pour voler des diamants.
Il y a assez longtemps, en utilisant
des méthodes de mentaliste.
Je pense que si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo,
vous allez aimer ces deux là.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !